we appreciate you being with us uh
anyway one of the one of Hunter's
American Business Associates was tasked
with facilitating a deal in China Tony
bobolinski is now sounding the alarm he
said the deal in China was not about
Hunter Biden or Jim Biden it was about
the Biden family LED and operated by Joe
Biden he now believes that Joe and the
entire family are compromised and
joining us now with more former Biden
family business associate you guys know
Tony bobolinski
[Applause]
okay so I'm glad we're investigating it
Joe Biden lied to the country when he
said and you know for a fact you were
there when he said that he had no
knowledge of Hunter's business well Sean
if you'll um humor me uh it's an honor
to be here at the Patriot Awards I'm a
I'm a United States bat I was a naval
officer my entire male family served
this country and what an amazing night
that Fox News puts on to recognize all
the prior vets future vets police
officers and First Responders so I'm
just uh my from myself and my family I'd
like to extend a you know a holiday
thank you to all those people that have
fought and defended this country thank
you for saying that thank you for your
service as well
um you know what we have some real
heroes here and by the way we're honored
we they give us this camera every night
so we have an opportunity to give a
story the rest of the media won't and
that's part of your story you met with
Joe Biden you met with Hunter Biden and
Joe Biden lied when he said he knew
nothing about hunter's business of farm
Business Association so this is tough
obviously we have four minutes and uh
this uh a little more yeah a little more
um uh you know out of respect for
Congressman Jordan and Congressman uh
Comer who are working really hard and
their teams are working really hard uh
just walking around the Patriot Awards
tonight I've had a hundred people
probably ask me hey is Justice gonna
happen what's going on with this and my
message to them is just be patient
um I think Congressman Comer is very
focused and uh Congressman Jordan are
very focused and
um obviously I've provided extensive
amount of facts uh two years ago I came
out publicly before the 2020 election
with the hope that all the American
people would be given those facts and
unfortunately through the collusion of
big Tech the FBI and the mainstream
media half the country never heard about
those facts and I think that's quickly
going to change uh starting this morning
with the press conference that
Congressman Comer and Congressman Jordan
had as well as uh to because I do want
to show due respect Senator Johnson and
Senator Grassley who've been working
tirelessly on this for years they both
won their re-election and um you know
thankful to the American people and they
have some great stuff the facts Sean the
facts matter
so we don't have to sensationalize it so
you know facts matter you know for a
fact because you were talking about
foreign business deals
not nothing illegal but you were talking
about it with Joe and Hunter and you're
in a room and you know for a fact that
when on Hunter's laptop where the
references to the big guy it was Hunter
Biden it was Joe Biden yeah I mean it's
crazy that we're actually still talking
about this two years after I've come
public a thousand percent Joe Biden is
the big guy uh Congressman Comer
addressed it this morning there is a
trove of facts and the good news for the
American people is um not only have I
come forward but in the last uh variety
of months multiple whistleblowers have
come forward with a whole Trove of facts
that cooperate everything I've said as
well as ADD incremental information to
it and um I think the American people
are going to see those facts I think
they're going to be shocked by those
facts and uh hopefully Justice is served
you've met you new Hunter you knew the
rest of the family did any of them have
any experience that they could offer
these countries in exchange for the
massive amounts some money we're talking
about but the good news once again is
the American people don't have to take
my word for it Hunter Biden in his own
words says he is putting his entire
family's family Legacy on the line to do
business with the Chinese Communist
Party CFC he says that in his own words
in numerous text messages and uh you
know other things that provided both to
the FBI and other whistleblowers so
don't take my word for it the good news
is Congressman Comer and Congressman
Jordan have troves of documents that
will um corroborate all this but a
thousand percent Joe Biden is the big
guy can I ask if you've met with all
these investigators I'm sorry have you
met with these investigators
um both Congressman Jordan and
Congressman Comer Norm uh more than
willing to cooperate and um as our
Senator Johnson Senator Degrassi so I'll
make myself available to them around the
clock so the only thing that the bidens
are offering is what their name and what
were these other countries
I mean you're sitting in the meetings
you know you're talking business you
know he has no experience
what why would anybody be offering the
type of money we're talking about look
at China for example 1.5 billion dollar
deal with the Bank of China you're going
to choose Goldman Sachs Deutsche Bank or
Hunter Biden or a hundred million
dollars from a oligarch former first
lady in Moscow why why were they doing
business with the bidens and at the end
of the day is it your belief being
involved in all of this that in fact our
national security is compromised with
Joe Biden as president good this will be
the last um hopefully last question
because I do want to get to uh Herschel
Walker who's been an inspiration to me
um our national security was compromised
by the Biden family I believe uh
Congressman Comer will prove that as
will Congressman Jordan
yeah there you go I'm giving you some
water by the way it's everyone clap for
him there you go
hell yeah I know we're live but uh you
know the Biden family was doing business
with the Chinese Communist party right
and you once again don't have to take my
word for it Hunter Biden says that in
the first person Joe Biden was well
aware of it in that audio recording
where he calls Hunter to acknowledge
that the New York Times was going to
release an article that talks all about
it and the FBI had this laptop now
forever and they didn't do a thing all
right last thing yeah
yeah so um I think your audience knows
this but the most important thing going
on in my mind in this country right now
is the next 20 days Persia Walker who's
a personal friend and has been an
inspiration to me since I was in my
young teens as an athlete enabled me to
develop the discipline that I applied in
athletics the Military College and
business so if it's not political to me
it's personal but what an inspiration he
was to me and he's an inspiration as a
man and anybody watching this team
Herschel dot com he needs help he's on
tonight he needs help he does team
hershel.com I'm going to Georgia voting
starts on November 28th through December
6th and people need to come out and
start voting and support him he's a
great man and our country needs him and
Georgia needs them Tony thanks for
stopping by Tony babalinsky everybody
all right
we have new details about the brutal
murders of poor Idaho college students
also Senator Ron Johnson reacts to his
exchange with the FBI director Ray about
hunter's laptop and who's going to
replace Nancy Pelosi in leadership I
vote for AOC I'll explain straight ahead
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else